أول ما طلع الخبر استرجعوا الناس
تاريخ من الفشل في التوسع في خدمات الاتصالات
عندنا محاولة في ماليزيا وإندونيسيا وتركيا
كلها كانت فاشلة، وصار فيها تخارجات
وعندنا محاولة فشلت حتى قبلما تبدأ اللي هي «فودافون»
فيه أسئلة كثيرة عن موضوع التفاوت سلم الرواتب
فيه كثير من زملائك القدامى
يقولون: أن أبو محمد يحب الجدد، وسلمهم أعلى من سلمنا
فتلاقي واحد جديد توه متعين، راتبة أعلى من راتبي
أنا اللي لي ثلاثة عشر سنة في «اس تي سي»
تشتروا نادي الشباب، وللا لا؟
نادي الشباب، خليني أتكلم لك على القطاع الرياضي بالمجمل
ويمكن أعرج لك عن توجهات الشركة الاستراتيجية
وفي الأخير بتجاوب على سؤالي
وفي الأخير بجاوب على سؤالك
طيب ممتاز
هذا سقراط من شركة ثمانية، وأنا عمر الجريسي
أستضيف قادة التحول والأعمال والرأي
ضيف حلقتنا اليوم هو المهندس عليان الوتيد
الرئيس التنفيذي لمجموعة «اس تي سي»
مجموعة عملاقة، ولها تاريخ ممتد من التحولات
والقطاعات المتعددة اللي اشتغلت فيها
فكان من المهم أن نبدأ بسرد سريع
لتاريخ المجموعة من البدايات إلى التخصيص إلى الاكتتاب
إلى أول رخصة مشغل جوال في 2004
الجوال موجود قبلها، قبل هذا التاريخ
لكن أول رخصة كانت في 2004
وما بعدها من التحولات
اليوم الشركة تنوعت في قطاعاتها لدرجة
أن صار بالنسبة للبعض في أزمة هوية، هذه بالضبط شركة أيش؟
فكان حديث ضيفنا عن شرح هذا التحول
من شركة اتصالات إلى شركة تقنية
أخذنا مجموعة من نماذج الشركات اللي وُلدت تحت هذه الشركة
مثل: حلول «اس تي سي»
وبنك «اس تي سي» أو «اس تي سي باي» سابقًا
«اس تي سي تي في» و«عقالات»
وغيرها من الشركات اللي اليوم تعمل تحت هذه المجموعة
تحدثنا عنها وعن طبيعة نشاطها
تكلمنا عن تحديات هذا التحول
وأيش التهديد اللي ممكن يجي من الإنترنت اللي عبر الفضاء؟
العلاقة مع الجهة المراقبة اللي هي هيئة الاتصالات وتقنية المعلومات
وبالتأكيد ختمنا بمجموعة من أسئلتكم الثمينة
أسئلة المستفيدين من الخدمات، مثل: سرعة الإنترنت
وضعف تغطية الشبكة في المناطق الجنوبية وبعض مناطق السعودية
تكلمنا عن مواضيع وأسئلة الموظفين
مثل: التعسف في السماح بستين يوم من العمل عن بعد
مثل: موضوع تفاوت سلم الوظائف في بعض قطاعات الشركة
وتكلمنا بالتأكيد عن مستقبل القطاع
وأهم التحولات والاستحواذات اللي صارت فيه، والمتوقع أنها تصير
وبالتأكيد تكلمنا عن الاستثمار في القطاع الرياضي
واستحواذهم على نادي الشباب
وغيرها من أسئلتكم الثمينة
أترككم مع الحوار
حيّاك الله أبو محمد، شرفتنا ونورتنا
الله يبقيك أبو يارا، الشرف لي الله يحفظك
الله يسلمك، أبو محمد حدثنا عن نجران
نجران مدينتي الجميلة الهادئة
مدينة جميلة بكل تفاصيلها وبأهلها وكرمهم وعاداتهم وتقاليدهم
أفتخر للأمانة أن أيام الصبا بدأت في نجران
يمكن أول ثمانية عشر سنة من حياتي كانت في منطقة نجران
وتخرجت من الثانوية العامة فيها
كانت لها أثر كبير في حياتي
بعدها يمكن انتقلت إلى الدراسة الجامعية في جامعة...
واللي ما يعرف نجران، وشلون تصفها له؟
مدينة جميلة في كل تفاصيلها للأمانة
سواءً كانت على الجغرافيا أو التاريخ أو الناس
فيها ثراء كبير جغرافيًّا، وفيها ثراء كبير أيضًا تاريخيًّا
وفيها عادات وتقاليد أبناؤها اللي يفتخرون فيها، ونفتخر فيها جميعًا
احنا عندنا حلقة في الموسم هذا مع «حصة السديري»
وتكلمت على...، هي مهتمة بالآثار
وتكلمت كثير على موضوع أهم المواقع في السعودية
ولما قلت لها: اختاري موقع وللا موقعين بحد أقصى
اللي أنت مرة منبهرة باللي فيها
وتعتقدين أن ما بعد أخذ حقه من الاهتمام
مباشرة قالت: نجران، واحد من الموقعين
فهي تتكلم على كمية نقوش هائلة
صحيح
تتكلم على مواقع، الظاهر واحد منها سُجّل في اليونسكو، وللا لا؟
صحيح «آبار حمى» من المناطق اللي سجلت في اليونسكو
فيها نقوش أثرية جميلة جدًّا، وتعكس تاريخ وحقبة تاريخية
تذكرها أنت؟
مريت عليها في فترة من الفترات
أيام الرحلات كنا نطلع ونشوفها
وأبو محمد يمكن هذا مثال جميل
على كيف أبناء المدن الغير رئيسية يصنعون فرصهم؟
أنت اليوم تقود ثاني أكبر شركة من حيث رأس المال في السوق
وأنت إلى عمر ثمانية عشر في مدينة ليست من المدن الرئيسية
وهذا يمكن نقاش اليوم بدأ يكثر
لما صارت كثير من المشاريع والفرص والشركات في الرياض
ويمكن جدة بدرجة أقل
فصاروا أبناء المدن غير الرئيسية يتساءلون
أن طيب، كيف أنا أصنع فرصتي، وكيف أكون جزء من الحراك القادم؟
لأن بطبيعة الحال، وهذا واضح
بأن نوع وحجم الفرص في المدن الرئيسية يختلف عن بقية المدن
فشلون يصنع أبناء المدن غير الرئيسية فرصهم؟
أنا أعتقد ما لها علاقة في مسألة مدن رئيسية أو مدن غير رئيسية
لها علاقة في مدى جدية الإنسان
سواءً كان جاي من مدينة رئيسية أو غير رئيسية
أن يأخذ حياته من مقتبل العمر بجدية
سواءً في دراسته أو في عمله
يمكن ما لها علاقة بمسألة أنه جاي من مدينة رئيسية وغير رئيسية
أكثر من أنه مدى جديته كإنسان أنه يأخذ الأمور بجدية كبيرة جدًّا
تبدأ في دراسته سواءً في المراحل الأولى أو في المرحلة الجامعية
كنت دافور أبو محمد، وللا لا ؟
كنت نوعًا ما دافور
كم تخرجت من الثانوي؟
تخرجت في 98.6%
ما شاء الله، وعلى وقتكم ترى لها وزن، الحين سهلة
لها وزنها
بس ذيك الأيام اختبارات وزارة أنتم؟
صحيح
فالثمانية وتسعين أهّلتك أنك تتقدم
على واحدة من أفضل الجامعات في السعودية
اللي هي البترول
صحيح، تخرجت من الثانوية، وبعدين كان الخيار واضح بالنسبة لي
قدمت في جامعة البترول فقط للأمانة
وكان التوجه أني أبغى أصير مهندس
وكان واضح بالنسبة لي، أيش أبي أصير
قدمت فيها، والحمد لله، قُبلت فيه وقتها
والحمد لله، الله وفق
في أيام الدراسة في الجامعة، استمتعنا فيها بشكل كبير
من الجامعات اللي تُثري طالبها بشكل كبير
والله وفّق، وانتهيت من الجامعة
وبعد كذا انضميت لسوق العمل في «اس تي سي»
وبعدين في أرامكو وبعدين رجعت لـ«اس تي سي»
وعلى طاري «اس تي سي»
احنا اليوم سعداء نستضيفك بصفتك قائد هذه الإمبراطورية العملاقة
واللي عاشت قصة تحول ما هي بسيطة
أنا أتذكر نشأت على فترة
كانوا يتكلمون على نهاية وموت شركات الاتصالات
وانتهاء نموذج العمل هذا
واليوم احنا نتكلم على خطورة شركة «اس تي سي» على قطاعات
أنها ممكن تؤدي إلى نهايتهم
فأنتوا كنتوا في خطر، وصرتوا اليوم مصدر خطر
فراح نسولف احنا على النموذج الجديد والتحول
لكن خلنا نذكر الناس ببدايات هذه الشركة
الشركة هي امتداد لعمل كانت الدولة تقوم فيه في فترة من الفترات
من بدايات السعودية من أيام الملك «عبدالعزيز» رحمة الله عليه
في الثلاثينيات كانت بدايات البرقيات
البرقيات كانت وسيلة التواصل ما بين مدن ومحافظات السعودية
وجدت في جميع المحافظات، ووجدت في جميع المدن في وقتها
وهذا يعطيك شيء مهم أن فيه اهتمام بعملية الاتصالات
من بداية الدولة السعودية
استمر هذا الاهتمام من قبل الدولة على مدار العقود
إلى أن وصلنا إلى عام 1998
عام 1998 كان فيه قرار لتخصيص قطاع الاتصالات
ومن هنا بدأ إنشاء شركة الاتصالات السعودية في آنذاك
هنا تبدأ مرحلة جديدة أن شركة قائمة بحد ذاتها، ولها ذمتها المالية
وعندها تفويض
وعندها عمل تخدم فيه المملكة العربية السعودية
بعدها يمكن فترة وجيزة طُرحت في سوق الأسهم في 2003
وكانت يمكن من أوائل الشركات اللي طُرحت بشكل كبير
وكانت تعتبر مرحلة انتقالية في تحول الشركة
من هنا بدأت العملية أن فعلًا صار فيه شركة مُدرجة في سوق الأسهم
ومطالبة أن يكون لها حَوْكمة
ومطالبة أن يكون لها إنجازات وأرباح وخسائر، وغير ذلك
بالإضافة إلى أنها مسؤولة عن البنية التحتية في المملكة العربية السعودية
هنا بدأت رحلة جديدة في 2004 إطلاق خدمة الجوال
ومن هنا كان في صعود كبير لخدمات الجوال في العالم بشكل عام
قبل 2004 كانت الهاتف الثابت؟
كانت الهاتف الثابت فقط
في عام 2004 بدأ الهاتف الجوال
وصار فيه استثمارات كبيرة من قبل الشركة
لنشر خدمة الجوال على مستوى السعودية
من هنا بدأت الشركة تنظر أن فيه فعلًا خدمة جديدة
والناس ترغب أنها تنظم إليها
وصارت تدر على الشركة أرباح
وصارت الشركة عندها القدرة أنها تستثمر بشكل أكبر
بعد كذا بدأ السوق يطمح إلى أن يكون في تنافسية أكبر
وهذا شيء مهم، وأنا أعتقد أنها كانت مفيدة لسوق الاتصالات
ومفيدة لـ «اس تي سي» نفسها
فتح التنافسية سواءً في سوق الجوال أو في السوق الثابت
كان لها أثر إيجابي كبير
2007 أتوقع الموبايل أخذت رخصة
وفتح الأسواق له فوائد كثيرة
من ضمنها أنها تحفز «اس تي سي»
بحكم إنها الشركة الأساسية في السوق
أنها تتحدى نفسها، وتتحدى التنافسية الموجودة
وتبدأ تستثمر بشكل أكبر في قدراتها وفي بنيتها التحتية
وفي أبنائها وبناتها اللي يمكّنونها أنها تقوم بعملها بشكل أفضل
يمكن الشركة في ذاك الوقت
بدأت تنظر إلى، متى يجب أن نتوسع في أعمالنا بشكل أكبر؟
وصار فيه توسعات واستثمارات في الفترة هذيك
وصار مدى قابلية الشركة أنها تكون منفتحة على نماذج أعمال جديدة
وهذا في 2006 و2007 صار فيه نموذج عمل جديد
إعادة هيكلة للشركة بشكل كبير
صار فيها توجهات أن ما نستمر بطريقتنا السابقة
وهذا يمكن يبيلي أعرّج عليه لاحقًا
أن مدى قابلية الشركة للتغير مع التحديات اللي تواجهها
أعادت سياقة نموذج العمل
وبدأت تركز بشكل كبير على الجوال، وتركز بشكل كبير على الثابت
والتوسع أيضًا
كل فترة من فترات تاريخ «اس تي سي»
تجد أن يعاد النظر في نموذج العمل بشكل مُقنّن
يتواءم مع حال السوق في حينه
ويتواءم مع المستقبل اللي احنا نبي نصل له بشكل استراتيجي
كل ثلاث إلى أربع سنوات يتم إعادة النظر في استراتيجية الشركة
وتستمر رحلة التحدي للذات
في 2007 يمكن بدأت أول استحواذ على «حلول اس تي سي»
اشتريناها بـ 100 مليون في وقتها، وسريعًا إلى الأمام
إلى أن وصلنا إلى قبل سنة ونص أو سنتين
طُرحت في سوق الأسهم بـ18 مليار
واليوم أكثر من 30 مليار قيمتها السوقية
فهذه الخطوات المتسارعة والمدروسة
كان لها أثر إنها تضع «اس تي سي» في وقت من الأوقات
تبدأ تنظر إلى احنا نبي نصير أكثر من اتصالات
يمكن وقت التحدي لما بدأت في بداية الحوار
تقول: الشركات كان عندها تحديات كبيرة
هنا بدأت «اس تي سي»
تبغى تطلع من فقط أنها مقدم خدمات الاتصالات
إلى مقدم خدمات الاتصالات بدون شك
أيضًا في تقنية المعلومات، ومجالات أخرى جديدة
من هنا بدأت تضع استراتيجيات فيها جُرأة شوي
يمكن سمينا الاستراتيجية «تجرأ»
والاستراتيجية هذه بُنيت على الموجة القادمة
الشيء الجديد في العشر سنوات المقبلة
«اس تي سي» أيش بتصير؟
باختصار «اس تي سي» قررت في ذاك الوقت يمكن في عام 2017
أن نبغى نكون شركة تقنية، بالإضافة لأنها شركة اتصالات
ولكن نبي نمشي في اتجاهات مختلفة
فالاتجاهات هذه حددت بشكل واضح
تقنية المعلومات والأمن السيبراني والكلاود والتكنولوجيا المالية
بالإضافة إلى شيء مهم بدأت فيه شركات الاتصالات على مستوى العالم
وهي فكرة لها علاقة بشيء يسمونه (Delayering)
«القضاء على الهيكلة» هذا أن تبدأ تنظر في الأصول الموجودة عندك
وتنظر إلى كيف تعظيم فوائد هذه الأصول الموجودة
الشركة فيها، ما شاء الله، أصول كبيرة جدًّا
أصول البنية التحتية سواءً الأبراج ومراكز البيانات والكابلات البحرية
ومن هنا نتج عنها شركات جديدة خلقتها «اس تي سي»
اليوم لو تنظر في المجموعة بشكل عام
تجد أن مجموعة فيها تكنولوجيا المعلومات والأمن السيراني
وفيها «آي أو تي، شبكة الكائنات المادية»
وفيها حوسبة سحابية والتكنولوجيا المالية وبنية تحتية
وفيها المركز «3» اللي هي مراكز البيانات والكيبلات البحرية
فيها محلات تجارية وتوزيع قنوات
وفيها «عقالات» اللي هي تقوم بإدارة أصول الشركة العقارية
فيها استثمارات في البحرين والكويت
وفيها استثمارات خارج السعودية سواءً في ماليزيا أو إسبانيا
الآن أنت جالس تطالع في شركة مركزة في هذه الجوانب بشكل كبير
استثماراتها في البنية التحتية شيء أساسي، وشيء مهم
وهذا جزء من الاستراتيجية
أن راح نستمر في الاستثمار بشكل فعّال وكبير
لأن هذا هو الأساس في وجودنا كشركة
وهذا هو الأساس في تقديم خدماتنا لعملائنا
إذا ما نجحنا هنا، لن ننجح في أي شيء آخر
كل الأشياء الجديدة هذه تبني على نجاحك في التفويض الأساسي
أو في وظيفتك الأساسية كشركة
واكب هذا التغير والرحلة الجميلة اللي ننظر لها رحلات أخرى
أنا أعتقد أنها مهمة كأهمية نماذج العمل، وأهمية التطور في العمل التجاري
لها علاقة بثقافة المنشأة، ولها علاقة بثقافة موظفين «اس تي سي»
وهذا شيء نفتخر فيه
أنا شخصيًّا من أبناء الشركة، وشفت وعشت الرحلة هذه
اللي فيها تجدد وتحدي، وفيها أن كل فترة جديدة ننظر كأبناء للشركة
أن وين راح نروح؟ نبغى نروح أبعد
والحمد لله، ثقافة الشركة الموجودة محفّزة
فيها مجال للناس أنها تعطي رأيها بشكل كبير
الشركة مستمرة بهذا التوجه بشكل كبير
وأعتقد جازمًا أن جزء من قوة «اس تي سي» هذا الانفتاح
على أنه نسمع آراء موظفيننا، ونسمع آراء عملائنا
ونسمع آراء مستثمريننا
ونعمل على أن احنا نقوم بشيء يخدم هذه الشريحة اللي تعطينا رأي
الرحلة مستمرة، أعتقد أن يمكن في الشعار الموجود في الشركة
احنا نقول: احنا رايحين أبعد
لأن فعلًا احنا رايحين أبعد، ونبي نروح أبعد
وبإذن الله تعالى، بجهود أبناء وبنات الشركة راح نروح أبعد
هذا ملخص جميل، يا أبو محمد للرحلة
الآن أحتاج أني أدخل في بعض محطاتها